you don't need trend spotters to tell
you because it's not hard to see that
our world cities have made me one way to
grow and that's vertically for a century
high-rises are made of concrete and
steel
now urban jungles are made of glass but
what did they conceal by the 1990s a
spirit of public housing had turned into
a ghost and the commodified glass condo
Rose is the new observation post all
over Asia pop-up cities mega cities and
super cities increase in relevance
while next gen slum clearance sweeps
through the developing world's informal
settlements urban slums once seen as
worthless are now tied with speculation
the rich returned downtown and pushed
the poor out into peripheral high-rises
a new form of deportation in New York
even old concrete blocks are the target
of speculators requiring only a Banks
persuasion a famous fight happened like
this in the building where hip-hop was
invented the tenants fought off
speculators attempts to have
gentrification augmented we're getting
all the signs as a middle-class declines
that most of the new vertical urban
future Alliance only for the very rich
or the very poor the city ceases to be
accessible to all for sure
the new luxury high-rise places are
getting smarter greener taller while the
new low-rent trend downtown is to make
the unit's smaller and smaller and
smaller some critics say these micro
apartments of less than three hundred
square feet are another way of combining
the young the lonely the cash-poor
into prison cell like retreat remember
the tenements this rampant privatized
vertical development in the future when
it comes such buildings made of glass
material that hardly lasts quite well to
turn into slums not all innovative
vertical communities are designed from
the top down a vertical squat and Krakus
is all the social features of a
functioning small town
you know 80% of Singapore residents
continue to live in public housing
proving that public concerns for
citizens can still be arousing and Hong
Kong's standard harmony blocks which
always rise to the 40th floor or more
are now being considered in China where
surprisingly public housing didn't
really exist before the legacy of mass
housing especially across Europe holds
some hope concrete blocks can be
renovated linked to the city and become
kind of dope scanning the centuries in
the history of the high-rise one sees
social patterns emerge disappear and
reprise vertical living can be modest
affordable and humane in the right
conditions it just needs us to think
about what our urban planet can be and
to redefine our ambitions